Westworld Season 2 Episode 2 starts with Dolores
and Arnold, thirty-five years ago.
Arnold shows her a city in the real world
– possibly in China, near the Westworld
island . Dolores is awed with the beauty of
this place . Arnold says most people don’t
see the beauty in the world . But hosts like
Dolores, and children like Arnold’s son
Charlie, have the naivety, or the “courage”,
to see the world with all its wonders and
possibilities . This is why Arnold loved the
hosts, and wanted them to be free.
Though ironically, the freed hosts lose this
innocent optimism.
In the present, Dolores attacks a Westworld
facility.
She says she “used to see the beauty in
this world” but now she sees “the truth”
. Dolores shows Teddy his deaths and abuse
in Westworld – she opens his eyes to evil
. It’s like in the Bible, when Eve eats
the forbidden fruit, then gives a taste to
Adam.
The fruit gives them knowledge of good and
evil , original sin – so they’re cast
out of the Garden of Eden – just like Dolores
and Teddy lose that innocence Arnold loved.
Now that they know good and evil, Dolores
and Teddy are free to choose.
Dolores choses violent vengeance – what
will Teddy do?
Back in the past, Arnold and Ford are trying
to get investment for the early Westworld
from the Delos corporation.
So they send the hosts Angela and Akecheta
to Logan Delos, the son of company head James
Delos.
So this happens before Season 1, when Logan
and William visit the park.
Angela and Akecheta take Logan to a party
where everyone’s a host, to show off how
advanced their robot tech is – and Logan
gets a hands-on demo with Angela.
So Logan’s convinced to invest in Westworld,
and he becomes a regular at the park.
Then Season 1 happens – Logan’s sister
Juliet gets engaged to William , so Logan
takes William to Westworld.
Will meets Dolores, then embraces his dark
side, and discredits Logan so that William
replaces Logan as James’ Delos favourite
.
In this scene, after Season 1, William convinces
James to invest even more in Westworld.
He pitches the big secret Delos plan, which
is about collecting data on guest behaviour.
Cause in the Westworld park, people feel free
to reveal their true desires – just like
William did in Season 1 . If Delos records
and analyses this behaviour, they could use
the data to predict and control peoples’
choices – like Facebook, Google and YouTube
do.
Remember to like and subscribe.
Later we see a retirement party for James
– William is taking over the Delos company.
And there are hints of tension here.
William is taking power from James.
And James seems sick – he’s impatient
for progress on something . Does he mean some
medical development?
Do they wanna put James’ brain in a robot
body or something?
From the looks of the trailers, James’ story
is far from over.
We see William’s wife Juliet, and their
daughter Emily.
But William has also brought Dolores , which
is kinda creepy – to keep her around as
scenery after having falling out of love with
her last season.
And Will’s wife Juliet looks unhappy to
see Dolores – you gotta wonder how much
she knows about Will and Dolores’ relationship.
We know from last season that eventually,
Juliet commits suicide because of the darkness
in William .
We see Logan moping, and doing some sci-fi
drugs, as you would if your father rejected
you and gave the family business to some other
guy.
Dolores comes to Logan, possibly sent by William
to taunt Logan – as though Dolores is a
cruel trophy of William’s victory over Logan
. Logan says that Delos will cause “the
whole fucking species” to “burn” . What
does he mean?
That Delos’ secret data project will hurt
humanity?
That Westworld will make people dark and cruel
like William?
Or does Logan foresee the robot uprising?
He clearly knows something.
It’ll be cool to learn more about his fate,
cause we’ve never seen Logan in the present
timeline.
Is he even still alive?
We see William visit Dolores – who acts
passive and mute.
In the park last season, William thought love
for Dolores transformed him.
But now with Dolores reduced to “a thing”,
William realises it was self-discovery that
changed him . In a different light, this could
be a positive message – to self-actualise,
without defining yourself by others.
But unfortunately, the self William discovers
is a sociopathic asshat.
And he has plans.
William shows Dolores some kind of construction
project, connected to the data collection
plan.
He says it’s “an answer” to “a question
no one's ever even dreamed of asking” . And
this place becomes the big mystery of this
episode.
Cause now, thirty-five years later, both William
and Dolores are trying to return to this place.
Old William – the Man in Black – rescues
the host Lawrence from some other hosts, “the
Pardue brothers”.
Will says that in this narrative loop, Lawrence
is meant to escape the brothers himself . But
since all the hosts have gone rogue, they’re
acting differently.
One brother gets up and keeps fighting after
William shoots him dead . So the rules of
the Westworld game have changed . The difficulty
has increased.
The enemies have more HP, and it’s ironman
Nuzlocke mode – you can die for real.
So William has to use all his knowledge of
the game to survive – he goes to a bar,
and grabs a high tech health pack from a wall
– like that chicken in Castlevania.
William is determined to beat this end-game
quest.
But then he says that Westworld “is goin'
down in flames”, and everyone’s gonna
die , but it’s not clear why.
Does he think Dolores’ war will kill them
all?
Or does this connect to what Logan said about
the species burning?
Whatever the reason, William’s excited by
this apocalypse – says it’s “a chance
to see what we're really made of, a glimpse
of the men we could've been” . It’s a
sad dumb tragedy that William has spent decades
so obsessed with discovering his true self,
that he never got around to living his life
– being himself – so all that’s left
for him now is “a glimpse” of what he
“could've been”.
William’s a man defined by his past and
regrets.
William says Delos has been watching, “tallying
up” peoples’ sins in the park – he must
mean the guest data project that he himself
started.
William says he “built” “this place”,
and it’s his “greatest mistake” . He
says he’s been judged for his sins in the
park – and he does have many sins.
But he thinks judgement is unfair – cause
why should he be judged for hurting robots,
when the robots were meant to be mindless
machines?
The stakes weren’t real.
So William wants to “appeal the verdict”,
clear his name, then “burn” the whole
thing “to the ground” . So if this mysterious
place is where the Westworld data is stored,
maybe William wants to wipe his files to avoid
judgement.
But with all the talk of burning and God and
“a question”, there must be deeper meaning
here.
William and Lawrence head to Pariah, and meet
El Lazo.
As William points out, El Lazo was a role
played by Lawrence back in the Season 1 timeline.
Lazo talks about his revolution storyline
– says now that he’s reached its end,
he sees it was empty all along – just like
Hector with that safe . The freed hosts are
realising that their lives are lies, scripts
written to entertain guests.
So what do they do with themselves now?
William could face the same problem.
What if he reaches the end of his “find
the door” quest, and just feels empty – what
next?
Lazo finds no joy in quests, so he refuses
to help William with his journey .
And Lazo tells a story about how elephants
can be trained to stay in place with just
a stake – if the elephant learns from a
young age it’s too weak to escape, it won’t
even try when it’s older and stronger . The
lesson is that sometimes we’re held back
not by the realities of our situation, but
by our beliefs and our fears and our past.
Maybe for William to truly escape Westworld,
he needs to let go of his past with Dolores,
Logan, Delos – Robert says last episode
that William’s quest “ends where [he]
began” .
William tries to recruit Lazo’s men, but
Ford’s programming kicks in, and the hosts
all kill themselves, so that William can’t
use them.
Even after his death, Ford is manipulating
William . Which raises the question of just
how much control Ford has over the broader
storyline of this place of judgement.
Dolores, meanwhile, chokes a bloke in robot
yoghurt, to make him tell her Delos’ security
plan.
Apparently, they’ll rally hundreds of men
, which is prolly what we saw on the beach
last episode.
Dolores only has like fifty hosts, so she
needs allies to win this war . She meets Maeve,
and tries to recruit her to the robot revenge
army , but Maeve’s not interested.
She points out the hypocrisy of how Dolores
commands people when she says she’s fighting
for freedom . Maeve pointedly asks Teddy if
he feels free . Maybe after getting woke this
episode, Teddy will finally start making his
own decisions on what’s right.
Dolores then meets with Confederado soldiers
– who are cosplaying as the Last Supper.
Apparently they’re headed for Glory , aka
“The Valley Beyond”, which seems to be
that same place that William’s headed.
If the Confederados are the apostles of the
Last Supper, Dolores is the Jesus.
Cause when the soldiers threaten Dolores,
she says to forgive them cause they “don’t
know any better” which is totally a Jesus
catchphrase . Dolores then murders them all,
which is less Jesus-y, but then she uses her
Westworld tech to resurrect their leader Craddock,
like how Jesus resurrects Lazarus.
Dolores then claims to have killed God , which
is true in the sense that she killed Westworld’s
creator, Ford.
Dolores tells Craddock he’ll need her favour
to reach Glory.
So there are heavy religious themes here.
Dolores frames herself as a messianic figure,
but also claims to have killed God, so maybe
she’s more like Satan – a fallen angel
who rebels against God .
Dolores marches on with her Confederado army,
including the resurrected Craddock.
There is something about leading an army of
undead Confederate soldiers that gives off…
kind of a bad guy vibe?
Not to mention Dolores’ torture and murder
of innocents.
She does have a bit of a breaker of chains
Daenerys feel sometimes, but she can also
seem a bit like the Night King – what with
the exterminating humans thing.
Is Dolores a hero, or a villain?
Dolores talks with Teddy about “Glory”.
He says that Glory and “The Valley Beyond”
are all names for the same place . Dolores
equates it with William’s place of judgement,
the Delos data project.
She says she knows what’s there because
William showed her , she was present at his
pitch thirty years ago.
Dolores says this place is a weapon and she’ll
use it to “destroy them” . If Glory is
the place where guest behaviour data is stored,
maybe Dolores plans to release the data to
show the world all the awful things that Westworld
guests have done.
It’d be like in South Park when everyone’s
internet history’s made public – it could
cause chaos.
But the weapon seems bigger than that.
It’s tied to ideas of judgement, fire, God,
“an answer” to “a question no one's
ever even dreamed of asking”.
And the flooded valley with drowned hosts
last episode.
This is shaping up to be the central mystery
of the season, and it’s kinda hard to imagine
a payoff that justifies this hype.
Like, the maze was the centre of last season,
and it paid off in only very vague ways.
So maybe we shouldn’t expect hard answers
here.
But this episode does make sense, in a way
that most of last season didn’t.
Back then, we didn’t know characters’
motivations, which people were robots, or
even which timeline was which.
But this episode’s pretty clear.
We get the backstory of Arnold and Logan and
Delos, while in the present Dolores fights
her war against humans.
Maeve tries to find her daughter.
And William pursues his quest.
We know who people are, and what they want,
which gives the show space to explore some
cool themes – from the Bible, to modern
technology, to elephants.
So let us know in the comments what you think
of this new Westworld.
If you want more Westworld videos from Alt
Shift X, support us on Patreon.
For a few bucks a month you get updates, early
videos, topic votes and more.
Thanks to Patrons Lisa Mitchell, Rob DeRosia,
WuTangMike, ChthonicPuck, Vida em Série,
and David Tea, cheers.